the opening scene features a young girl
named Mary who is playing with her cat
shining in her backyard where an
unidentified person suddenly appears
from behind and abducts her in the next
scene we see a stranger who enters a
small Town's police station amidst a
Christmas Eve rainstorm he approaches
Sergeant gulloy at the front desk and
expresses his intention to confess when
asked for more details The Stranger
reveals that his confession is about a
murder hearing this Sergeant gulloy
becomes alarmed and aims a handgun at
him before calling for backup from his
colleagues following this all the
officers walk out at the desk and
instruct the stranger to place his hands
on his head the team leader detective
Alexander black then orders the officers
to take the stranger to the
interrogation room inside the
interrogation room two police officers
named Deputy Jack Hawkins and Deputy
Jerry Pine questioned the stranger about
his identity however the stranger
insists on being known as Mr Nobody
refusing to disclose his real name his
real name must be something like Perkins
or Peabody as the interrogation
progresses The Stranger deliberately
provokes Jack prompting the officer to
almost assault him at the same time
detective Alexander enters the room and
interrupts the situation he tries to
extract information from The Stranger
but Mr Nobody remains unresponsive as a
result Alexander instructs the officers
to mugshot and fingerprint him before
placing him in a Cell just before
leaving Mr nobody notices a dedication
text on detective Alexander's golden
metal pen and remarks upon it this draws
the suspicion of the detective who seems
to have received that pen from his
missing daughter Mary on the other hand
in a secret room of the police station
Deputy Toby Sherwood and Deputy Jane
Hollows are engaged in a private moment
during this Jane experiences a vision of
Mr Nobody watching them from a distance
however the mysterious figure vanishes
when she looks at it for the second time
Toby inquires about what she saw but she
dismisses it as a possible hallucination
caused by excessive caffeine if coffee
could do that I'd be tripping balls all
the time meanwhile the officers find
themselves perplexed upon discovering
that the stranger does not possess any
fingerprints in light of this Revelation
Jack decides to cross-reference the
stranger's appearance with past criminal
records for this he firstly examines the
recently taken mug shot of Mr Nobody and
is startled to find that it has only
captured the clothes The Stranger was
wearing just then Jack hears the
stranger whistling an eerie tune which
sends shivers down his spine
[Music]
however he conceals his fear and steps
outside to calm himself with a cigarette
shortly after Alexander instructs his
subordinates to bring the stranger back
to the interrogation room for further
questioning Toby then asks Galway about
the cell in which the stranger has been
held to which the latter responds with
cell number four Toby and Jerry proceed
to that particular cell only to discover
it empty surprisingly The Stranger is
moved to cell number three despite this
unusual occurrence the officers did not
pay much attention and dismiss it as a
simple oversight on gulloy's part
outside the police station Jack's
trembling hand shows his fear as he
smokes clearly affected by recent events
moments later he heads inside and
confides and Jerry that the stranger
Bears a striking resemblance to a
Drifter whom they had arrested a year
ago during their investigation Into The
Disappearance of Mary Black when they
were unable to prove him guilty Jack and
the others resorted to assaulting him in
an attempt to extract a confession even
though the accused vehemently maintained
his innocence however Jerry dismisses
Jack's claim urging not to dwell on it
after this Jack proceeds to the basement
to inspect the underground cells while
Alexander and the remaining officers
continue the interrogation of Mr Nobody
The Stranger who confesses to six
murders chillingly describes the details
of his first killing astonishingly Jack
begins to experience the described
torture firsthand even though the
stranger himself remains confined Mr
Nobody claims to have stalked his victim
imprisoned him in a dark room and
subjected him to a brutal assault in
parallel Jack finds himself trapped in
one of the dimly lit cells enduring a
vicious beating on his back the sound of
his screams reaches the ears of the
other officers prompting Alexander Jerry
and gulloy to rush to the basement to
their horror they discover the lifeless
body of Jack overwhelmed by shock they
immediately handcuffed The Stranger and
lock him up in the interrogation room
before embarking on a thorough search of
the area Jerry and Goliath cautiously
venture outside armed with their guns to
investigate the surroundings suddenly a
lifeless cat's body falls onto gulloy's
head sending him into a state of panic
it didn't even land on its feet upon
closer examination they discover a
collar on the cat's neck bearing the
name shining which makes them realize
that it is the same cat Mary used to
play with they quickly report their
findings to Alexander who is unable to
understand what's going on Jerry then
recalls Jack's earlier claim shares it
with the others revealing that the six
of them had wrongly arrested and
subjected an innocent man to torture in
the past all for the sake of Mary
Galloway informs the group that the
victim of their unjustified violence is
still in a coma being cared for at a
medical facility in the midst of their
discussion they hear footsteps on the
roof prompting Alexander to send gulloy
and Jerry to investigate while the
remaining three officers return to
continue their investigation with the
stranger Mr Nobody then proceeds to
describe his second victim asserting
that the person was a coward who made no
attempt to fight back according to the
stranger's account he approached the
victim from behind strangled him with a
robe and hanged him to death
astonishingly Galloway's body suddenly
appears outside the window suspended by
a rope exactly how the stranger
described the officers are gripped with
Terror stop fooling around out there
galoy prompting them to confine The
Stranger in his cell and to decide to
contact the medical facility to gather
information about The Drifter to their
shock they discover that the victim had
died early earlier that evening
precisely at the same time the stranger
entered the police station this
Revelation proves that the stranger is
not the person they believed him to be
following the mysterious deaths of two
officers the remaining members of the
group resolved to seek assistance from
other officers they attempted to contact
them through radio signals but their
efforts proved futile following this
Toby and Jane set off in search of help
driving through the woods as they
proceed they come across another patrol
car and decide to pull over stepping out
of their vehicle they investigate the
other police car but find it empty
meanwhile at the police station
Alexander and Jerry approached the
stranger's cell to their shock The
Stranger expresses his Readiness to
confess to yet another murder
recognizing a pattern Alexander
frantically instructs Jerry to contact
their two colleagues and summon them
back to the station Jerry hurries to the
control room attempting to reach Toby
and Jane through the radio unfortunately
the bad weather causes poor signal
reception preventing him from reaching
them at the same time the stranger
proceeds with his confession describing
how he awaited his third victim in a
dark location despite Alexander's
command to stop talking Mr Nobody
disregards the order and reveals that
upon the victim's arrival he positioned
himself between them in response
Alexander draws his gun and Fires at the
stranger startled by The Sound Of The
Gunshot Jerry runs back to the cell only
to find that Alexander is firing it at
an empty space moments later The
Stranger reappears in a different cell
declaring that he had mercilessly
attacked his third victim simultaneously
in the woods Toby scans the surroundings
in search of their fellow officers while
Jane attempts to fix the radio signal
inside the car suddenly Toby is ambushed
from behind and fatally stabbed with a
shovel shortly after Jane realizes
Toby's absence and calls him out by name
but receives no response
she investigates the area she discovers
his ravaged body and becomes terrified
in a state of panic she hastily gets
back to the car and drives back to the
police station upon her arrival Jane
tells her superiors about what she had
witnessed with this Alexander finally
grasps the chilling truth that the
stranger's confessions manifest as
actual killings with each confession
resulting in a corresponding death
moreover Alexander deduces that the
stranger may be the vengeful Spirit of
The Drifter they had tortured in the
past haunted by the injustices inflicted
upon Him Alexander should change his
name to Sherlock following the harrowing
events the three remaining officers make
a desperate decision to flee the police
station and find a safe place Jane takes
the driver's seat as the trio gets into
the car unfortunately the car fails to
start Alexander and Jerry step out to
inspect the engine leaving Jane inside
in an eerie turn of events the radio
mysteriously activates emanating the
voice of the stranger it's me
says the voice the stranger declares
that it is time for another confession
sending Jane into a state of Terror she
attempts to escape from the car but
finds the door locked frantically she
screams for help and Alexander and Jerry
exert all their strength to shatter the
car window but to no avail inside Jane's
head gets ensnared in a plastic bag
causing her to suffocate despite
Alexander and Jerry trying to break the
window they are unable to save Jane
amidst this commotion the voice on the
radio proclaims that the Unleashed wrath
from the unknown depths has come to
claim her in death after some time
Jane's head is detached from her body
and falls out of the car filled with
panic Jerry decides to kill the stranger
they have held captive he enters the
police station with his gun approaches
the cell and starts firing relentlessly
at the stranger until his ammo runs out
once he finishes Jerry enters the cell
only to discover that it is completely
empty moments later The Stranger
narrates his next confession announcing
that his fifth victim never saw him
coming without delay Mr Nobody attacks
Jerry committing yet another brutal
murder having witnessed this horrific
act Alexander the sole remaining officer
attempts to flee however the stranger
asserts that Alexander cannot hide in
the darkness
and that every pass leads to him just as
he said Alexander enters a club for help
but somehow ends up inside the police
station where he is confronted by The
Stranger once again helpless Alexander
offers an apology for assaulting an
innocent suspect in response The
Stranger reveals a shocking truth he was
the one responsible for murdering
Alexander's daughter the detective is
shaken by this Revelation and demands an
explanation for the unfolding nightmare
The Stranger claims that he sought
Revenge according to him he had
languished in a coma for nearly a year
and all this time he dreamed of
Vengeance The Stranger then proceeds to
make his final confession revealing that
detective Alexander black is his
ultimate victim however before the
stranger can divulge more details
Alexander impales his own ears with his
daughter's golden metal pen desperately
attempting to avoid hearing the
confession seeking Refuge Alexander
hides beneath a desk where he
experiences a vision of his deceased
daughter in this Vision Mary informs him
that the stranger is an evil person but
Alexander has the power to stop him when
asked how Mary discloses that the
stranger despises his own name and
wishes to keep it Anonymous nonetheless
Mary tells him that she knows the
stranger's name and Whispers it into his
deafened ear how did he hear it then
armed with this newfound knowledge
Alexander Rises clutching his gun and
boldly addresses The Stranger by his
name Stanley harperton I knew it was
nerdy this unexpected Revelation
unsettles The Stranger and seizing this
opportunity Alexander fires his shotgun
at the stranger causing him to plummet
through a window and vanish from sight
in the aftermath of this event the sun
ascends on the following Christmas Day
Alexander catches a final glimpse of his
daughter on the stairs she bids him
farewell with a wave and walks away
presumably leaving for the afterlife
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching